[Music]
mr quest master
rock paper scissor
[Music]
how do you relax and reset between races
i like to watch some darts
it's easy to uh
yeah to watch and
they they count for you so you don't
have to kill yourself so guards is a
good one
who's the biggest character in the team
um
i'm quite new so
i would say luke
he's the
speaker from us in the team yeah and
yeah he's close contact i think also to
the management and stuff yeah i would
say look yeah i would say look as well
he's quite focal and
he's a captain
after ryze
so what
tv series are you watching right now
i just um finished on the cover
it's like a dutch
[Music]
netflix
there you go you like it yeah what's
good yeah
do you all watch the whole season sorry
i think only two
i didn't like the second one so much but
the third one is really great so if you
have a chance then
okay i would go for it
what's your favorite sis product and
what's your flavor
um if i'm straightforward i would say
the energy bake um how's the flavor um
gary michel of course yeah
if you had one
superpower what would it be
i i want to fly yeah just want to
fly skip the traveling yes get the
traveling yeah that's nice but then you
can travel yourself if you if you can
fly you know
what do you eat before a typical race
i think i'm pretty simple with that just
normally omelet
and
porridge
with muesli i think
but nothing nothing special muesli is
quite german
i don't know
what's your advice for anyone uh looking
to get into racing
like i started off as
a bmx ride actually
and i just
started because i liked it you know and
i think that's the main
um
main reason to keep on going you know i
i wasn't any good or
until i was 16 or 17. yeah um but just
because i really liked it and i was just
loving to ride my bike
um
yeah that helped me
probably where i'm now you know so
yeah my advice is just
enjoy riding the bike and
then the rest will come
any superstitions
uh
not really i would say
um i don't care if i have the number 13
on my back no no don't turn it
i i turn it but there you go yeah yeah
there you go yeah but it's not like
i'm afraid of to have yeah
so yeah i turn it
but also looks cooler
so
um but you never know you know maybe if
you don't turn it then you're done so
it's better than you just always turn it
no yeah
what's your favorite post-race meal poor
i mean if i can choose i would
have everyday pizza of course
after after ripe or like
some fries or a burger
[Music]